before i begin i feel it is necessary to
point out that the news arm of the bbc
has yet to retract apologize or
otherwise address the deeply transphobic
reporting it has engaged in in the last
few months in a pinned comment down
below you'll find my original video on
the topic several videos from the
youtuber sean who has been ongoing in
his pursuit of trying to get the bbc to
own up to what they have done and also a
video from laura kate dale showing the
protests that have taken place outside
of the bbc offices while i don't feel
any of the people behind doctor who are
in any way responsible for this i cannot
in good conscience talk about a bbc
owned property without mentioning this
first until such time as it is properly
redressed thank you
and the rumor mill keeps on spinning
[Music]
hey folks so um i bounced what i was
originally going to plan
and have out on saturday don't worry
it'll still happen it'll just be later
and instead i'm going to talk about some
of the latest rumors around doctor who
and what russell t davis is potentially
planning now interestingly the part i
was most dubious about with this uh has
pretty much already been debunked i'll
address it quickly anyways but there's
another part that people weren't
focusing nearly as much on because it
wasn't the part that everybody always
speculates about and that i think is
actually
much more
uh worth examining and dry and drilling
in on so what we're talking about here
is a piece originally published by the
british paper the mirror
paper might be generous i think tabloid
is how it's usually referred to now the
mirror has
let's go with a mixed history when it
comes to predicting things in relation
to doctor who specifically they have
gotten some things right even in recent
years which is part of why i avoid these
things because stuff that these things
published were spoilers it turned out in
some cases but
this time
they put out a piece where the big
headline and the main thing that
everyone focused on was the idea that
actor hugh grant was going to be the
doctor following on from jody whittaker
and then there was some other stuff in
there and that's what i'm going to spend
more time on but let's deal with the
hugh grant thing real quick first of all
most of this is moot right now because
hugh hunt himself put out a tweet
responding to it nothing against doctor
w but i'm not
no idea where that story came from so
that feels like should kind of be the
end of it but i still want to address a
couple things about it first is the
general idea honestly
i think he might potentially have been a
decent doctor it is known that he was
actually offered the part before
christopher ecclestone was back when the
show was first revived and he has in the
past expressed regret about that which
might have been part of what fueled the
speculation another potential thing that
might have fueled the speculation it's
not impossible for him to be in talks to
appear in the show just not as the
doctor there have been some very big
name people including some for whom
there was speculation or at least a fan
desire in some cases that maybe that
would be the doctor i'm talking about
people like bill nye appearing during
matt smith's run so it's not out of the
realm of possibility that he could
appear much like his fellow curse of the
fatal death alum richard e grant
ultimately did appear several times in
his case as a villain so i wouldn't be
super shocked if we do see
that hugh grant does appear somewhere in
doctor who maybe as a one-off maybe it's
something more meaningful
but i wouldn't be surprised if he is
actually going to appear and that's part
of where the wires got crossed with the
mirrors reporting
it's also possible it's completely
nonsense but do note that
grant's denial really only says he's not
the doctor doesn't say he's not involved
anywhere
and as far as the general idea of him
playing the part i mean the main reason
i was skeptical mostly had to do with
his age he's currently 61 uh which is
two years older than peter capelli was
when he finished playing doctor who so
i think the the burden of filming on
this thing asking that of someone that
age it probably would have been a lot
not that he would have been incapable of
doing it but i think it would have lent
itself to amongst other things probably
only a single series and i think
starting to get big names for the doctor
for only short runs is probably not a
good thing for the long-term health of
the show people willing to commit to
more series is going to be a good thing
and while his age doesn't necessarily
preclude that it makes it less likely
now he has been doing more tv over the
years but it's been like limited run
series like three episode miniseries and
things like that
there's a real big workload difference
between that and taking on doctor who so
those are the main reasons i was
skeptical about it i while i think he
actually probably could play the part
very well he's become a very interesting
performer
the other thing is that
well first of all i personally am still
pulling for joe martin assuming that uh
it's logistically possible a and b she
actually wants to continue on with the
part it's possible she doesn't want to
in which case i'm not in a position to
insist that she do it but that's what i
would like but failing that i am just in
the meta context i am not thrilled at
the idea of the next doctor being a
pasty white dude
like i just think that it's going to
unfortunately
lend itself to the perception in certain
fan circles that jody whitaker was a
mistake
that when they deviated from white male
template that
well things went wrong we go right back
to it if they are not going to bring in
joe martin i'm not even going to say it
has to be another woman i would kind of
prefer it to be but it doesn't have to
be but at the very least just not
another white man because i honestly do
fear that if we go right back to that it
will actually make it harder at least
within fan communities to get fans to
accept even someone who isn't white
playing the part and i know that sounds
counterintuitive but it will be framed
again by certain aspects of fandom not
that we should be making every move in
like to be aware of these kinds of fans
but like
this is this would be a thing that
happened they would insist well any
deviation from white male was the
problem in this case it was a woman but
they shouldn't have deviated at all and
it becomes ammunition for that argument
which
i don't love but
that is more of a meta issue than an
actual problem with grant but let's deal
with the other thing that was in that
article the thing that i think carries a
lot more weight
and that i also actually
might even have more concerns about
so the other thing that was in that
article was the talk of
davies wanting to put together something
like a marvel cinematic universe
equivalent
for doctor who this uh factors off a
couple of things that make this more
than i think just a rumor it's at least
pretty plausible
number one it's worth noting that nearly
every spin-off that happened for the
previous time with doctor who davis
signed off on or if if not was involved
directly so for torchwood sarah jane
adventures but then after he left there
seemed to be way less appetite for
spin-offs at all
like they tried with class that got one
series and then that was it we haven't
had a spin-off since
now
in my personal opinion the quality of
these spin-offs varies
wildly
so that's
kind of its own thing but that's more of
an issue with the product not
necessarily an issue with the core idea
but there has already been talk amongst
fans about maybe he'll bring back
spinoff something which is a
conversation i haven't really indulged
because it didn't seem all that likely
to me the thing that's different now
is that production for doctor who is no
longer going to be at bbc wales it's now
being handled by bad wolf productions
which is the uh studio owned by the
producers where davies is going to be uh
doing all this out of now here's the
thing about that
sony
as in
the playstation owned spider-man in the
movies sony
they bought a majority stake in bad wolf
now i saw some people really
misconstrued like they own doctor who
now no they don't this wasn't a purchase
of property rights uh intellectual
property rights this was just a purchase
of the studio where the production is
currently going to be going on it wasn't
a total purchase it was a majority stake
which means
they basically have veto power if they
want to do that but anyways
what this means is
that it overcomes one of the potential
hurdles of bringing back the idea of
spin-offs because something that i have
kind of had in the back of my head
especially when class really didn't do
much was that i have a hard time buying
that the bbc would put the resources
either financial or time slots
behind something that
just hadn't really been working out for
them that great up to that point
but now with sony backing the studio
that's actually going to be handling the
filming there is not only potentially
more resources to work with but also
potentially more incentive because
sony's gonna want more bang for their
buck and more things being produced
in connection to the largest of the
properties that bad wolf is going to be
having its hands on yeah
that's something that you could
definitely see they would want to have
happening you could see them offering to
at least partially finance such a thing
whereas before since production of
doctor who was in-house at a bbc studio
that meant the bbc had to foot the bill
for these things every time they tried
to do a spin-off now there's probably
less
much less potentially financial
commitment that the bbc has to do in
order to indulge these ideas
which makes it a lot more likely for
them to come back
which concerns me now first thing to be
fair is doctor who a universe in which
there is the room for expansion
well yeah
you can look at big finishes catalog for
the mountain of material some of which
is very good and does not involve the
doctors at all there are companion
stories stories about units stories
about characters who only appeared in
the show once like jago and lightfoot
they run the gamut and they've really
explored a lot of corners of this thing
and it definitely shows that there is
the potential for stories to be told
with all kinds of corners of doctor who
so i'm certainly not going to make the
argument that the story or the world
that doctor who said it doesn't support
additional material because that would
be very silly of me to argue
i am personally however of the opinion
that that kind of material is best
explored
in
uh more optional media
like comic books novels or the audio
dramas
bringing it in the form of more spin-off
shows is something that i personally
have slightly less of an appetite for
now i may very well be alone in that so
i'm not going to make an argument that
it's objectively bad
but
okay so
there's a couple of things here
when it comes to expanding out things
everyone likes to compare things to the
mcu because the mcu is the most
successful version of this when it comes
to film and television it just is
whether you like it or loathe it it is
the most successful there is no question
about that
however i actually don't think that
works as a comparison for doctor who i
think a more valid point of comparison
would probably be star wars
and here's what i mean by that
star wars for all the expanded material
that has ever been done about all kinds
of corners from video games to novels to
comics to all sorts of stuff
the main core of star wars
has been the skywalker story that's why
that's been what the movies are with the
right now only exceptions being solo
and rogue one
so
i feel like knowing that the doctor is
the central pillar through which
audiences partake of doctor who the
franchise
and knowing that the skywalkers were the
central pillar through which most
audiences experienced star wars i feel
like that's a sounder connection and
comparison
than the mcu is which from the very
beginning was built up with multiple
pillars right from the start we got iron
man and then shortly after that we got
the hulk we got captain america we got
thor
before they all got teamed up and now as
we have seen the originator of all that
iron man has been retired and the thing
still moves forward it wasn't built
around a single central pillar it was
built around multiple which has allowed
it to expand out i think with a bit more
freedom
doctor who is built centrally
around
the doctor
and the idea of the spin-off media
gives me the same sort of
that might start feeling like homework
feeling that i get with a lot of the
star wars stuff that's coming out if you
haven't been watching my star wars
review over on the break room of geeks
you can check out that channel over
there
i've been tepid
like i
i have not had the time
to get into something like the clone
wars or rebels i've watched the first
season of the mandalorian it was okay
i tried to start the second but i had
other things to do and i just found i
didn't care that much
i watched the book of boba fett and was
enjoying it up until it turned into the
mandalorians season 2.5 at which case i
got really frustrated
and then there's things like star wars
visions which frustrated me and like i'm
not saying it's bad that these things
exist but i'm looking at potential
spin-offs thinking at least in my head
that comparing doctor to star wars makes
more sense and then subsequently looking
at the fact that i don't
like
most of the
ancillary star wars material
and i kind of never have
and i worry especially at this point
because
again regardless of whether or not you
like chimney zera and jody whitaker on
the part
this has been a divisive era of doctor
who and it would help for the overall
health of the franchise to have
something that can be a bit more broadly
appealing i'm not saying like go go
mainstream and make it simple for the
math that's not what i'm saying but i'm
saying
aiming for something that that can that
more of the fandom can rally around
again i'm not saying to uh try and
appease the
not my doctor types because they will
never be happy and it's not worth it but
um just broadly speaking there's plenty
of people who are just
not super in love with this era who
could be brought back and i would really
be afraid
if we ever find out or if it just
transpires that
rather than pouring all resources right
now at least
into the core show of doctor who making
that as good as it can possibly be
focusing everybody's attention there
if that is getting diverted to start
planning
spin-offs already even if you're not
putting logistical resources towards it
like production or whatever but you're
even just spending time planning it or
you're building your new era of doctor
who around the idea of creating
spin-offs
if that is true
that to me indicates
a shift in priorities and a lack of
focus i'm not saying you can never
do spin-offs but i would say
nail down your main thing first
and get doctor who
established as what you intend it to be
however similar or different from the
current era that is but make sure that
you have established here's what doctor
who is now
and at least get a sense and a gauge of
how people are taking it before you
start planning on new media to attach to
it
and again
this is not a definite
this is again part of the reporting
where at least half of it the hugh grant
half has been more or less debunked so
that does throw into question the rest
of the reporting but as i said i can't
see a scenario where there was
information related to who grant just
wasn't as they reported
and logically
this general idea makes
sense
and it makes enough sense that it is
feasible possible and this is a
production team and a creative heads
who would want to do it
because they've done it
before
and if that is part of the appeal and it
like this could very well have been part
of why
russell agreed to do this at all
this could honestly be part of why rtd
agreed to come back at all he may have
been given
enough creative control which is already
kind of indicated by the fact that it's
now happening at a studio run by his
long time
uh partners as long time creative
partners
rather than at a bbc studio directly
that already indicates that the bbc is
handing over a lot of control
now
we don't know if that was a condition
from uh davies that for him to take over
or if it was something that the bbc
actually kind of wanted to do anyway
they just didn't want to be dealing with
the direct production costs themselves
anymore and by moving it over there to a
studio that is now partially backed by
sony allowed them to defer some of those
costs that's distinctly possible as well
maybe rtd wanted it maybe they just
wanted to unload it it's kind of
impossible to know maybe it's a little
bit of both
but given his history with doctor who
specifically given the resources that
are available and the larger entities
that are now involved in the studios if
not with the doctor who franchise itself
i think the spin-off
reporting has a good chance of being
true
and if it's true it worries me that
there's enough momentum behind it
that it's being reported this
early
that is just going to be a point of
worry for me because while i can admire
someone with the confidence to come in
and go okay i've got a plan for this
thing we've got that but i've also got
plans for this this and this that'll be
tied to it i can admire that ambition
and that confidence
but i can still think that's a bad idea
and
as i always say whenever i get skeptical
about anything that i have a commitment
and um
uh you know i care about
i hope i'm wrong
i mean
i hope i'm wrong in the sense that
they're not actually planning on doing
uh spin-offs or or at least not even
brainstorming right at this point but if
i'm wrong and they are doing that
i hope my fears are wrong
if they do this i hope it's amazing
i hope they blow me away hope i eat
these words
but i needed to spend some time talking
about that and uh you know just to grant
the a grant address the hugh grant thing
kind of offhandedly
because yeah
it's uh it's been a bit
it's been going on so
that's i think all i've got to say about
this
i'm nervous
and i'm trying to remind myself of the
excitement of rtd coming back because
i want to see what he's going to do
different
i've said that before
he's a different creator he has
different leanings different
inclinations he's matured
in a lot of ways
and i want to see what that brings to
doctor who
which is just one more reason for me to
get kind of nervous at the idea that
it's jumping right into handling doctor
who
the way he did last time because he did
spin-offs last time let's plan spin-offs
show me what's new
before going back
to stuff you've already done which is
not to say that like it would directly
bring back torchwood or something i
think there's rights tied up with that
at this point but
just broadly
focus
in give me
doctor who right now
show me you've got this
and then i can get excited about the
possibility of spin-offs
maybe potentially i'll probably still be
skeptical about that realistically
because i'm me
but what are your thoughts about all
this whatever they are drop something
down in the comments let's talk about it
like share subscribe they all help me
out patreon is what really helps me out
pays the bills enables me to do this as
my job but even if you're not able to do
that it's okay
what i really want you to remember is
that you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you are the council i'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
it's the end credits means i gotta shout
out some patrons this month it is turok
oliver b melinda walters tt
robin powell for knobby lax the poodle
idoln tracy scrabbon dharma michael
doyle vincent paul bartolucci angry
casper adam lefty taylor robin moore
shayla gourley and bookworm
thanks so much for your support
[Music]
[Music]
now
[Music]